battlefield one is arriving very soon
for those of you who didn't crowd the
early enlist tradition and given all the
hype and epic review scores that have
been rolling in I figured we'd take a
look at everything you can do in the
latest battlefield installment the world
war one shooter includes the kinds of
weapons and vehicles you'd expect from
the era you'll be using bolt-action
rifles automatic and semi-automatic
weapons artillery flamethrowers Sabres
trench clubs shovels and a tiny tiny gun
the melee combat has been reworked and
weapons are divided into heavy and light
categories when you get tired of walking
you can hop into a variety of tanks on
the trucks biplanes and battleships and
even Zeppelin if you prefer horses can
also be written into battle much like
earlier battlefield games destructible
environments and weapon customization
our returning auto filled single-player
is comprised of five independent war
stories which you can complete in any
order each highlights a different
protagonist a different location and a
different part of the world war 1
conflict the game's prologue storm of
Steel is set in France and places you in
the shoes of several Harlem Hellfighters
when you die in this section you'll see
the name
Berthier and hear of death of a real
soldier through mud and blood is also
set in France but you'll take on the
role of a British tank driver friends in
high places has you starring as a Royal
Flying Corps fighter pilot avanti savoia
takes place in italy and highlights the
plight of a mournful survivor a runner
features an antic runner on the
Gallipoli Peninsula and finally nothing
is written puts you in the boots of a
Bedouin warrior in Mesopotamia under the
command of Lawrence of Arabia
battlefield ones multiplayer supports up
to 64 players and the new squad system
lets a group of players enter and leave
service together there are 9 maps and 6
modes to talk into which include
conquest domination rush team deathmatch
and two new modes operations and war
pigeons operations these teams fighting
across several maps in a mixture of
traditional rush and conquest gameplay
while war pigeons is a new take on
capture the flag as teams compete to
capture a pigeon and release a message
to win the round the maps are based on
locations around the world including
Arabia the Alps and the Western Front
the eight classes you can choose
include assault medic support scouts
tanker pilot cavalry and elite which of
the glass you obtain through a pickup on
the battlefield and allows you to use
different special abilities or weapons
such as the flamethrower each class has
specific spawn bonuses a weaponry and
advantages versus certain enemies dice
have said that battlefield one will be
more dynamic than earlier installments
and the single-player will feature
larger and more open environments than
what you're used to from the battlefield
series don't take my word for it though
check out our review on site or pick up
the game for yourself when it arrives on
October 21
you